oh good evening and thanks for joining
us I'm Vanessa Murphy a Southern
California pipeline supplying gas to the
Las Vegas Valley is now repaired that's
after a leak was discovered which
prompted Nevada's governor to declare a
state of emergency last night now
Governor Joe Lombardo says the fuel
issue is fixed Joshua peguero Joins us
live from the Costco on MLK and Symphony
Park with the latest on what drivers are
seeing at gas stations Joshua
hello Vanessa the governor and Clark
County officials are urging the public
not to Panic by but as you can see with
this line here you know some folks
didn't get the memo or they're choosing
to ignore it
I called my dad and loved ones like hey
go get gas because you just never know
there wasn't a long line at this
7-Eleven gas station on the west side of
the valley but the topic of conversation
for those filling up was the ruptured
pipelines we do have gas it's not like
we're out you know people think that no
the league found on Thursday disrupted
gas flow Kinder Morgan operates the
affected pipeline located in Long Beach
California it transports gas diesel and
jet fuel to Barstow California and Las
Vegas I gotta fill my equipment with gas
I got to fill my van with gas and I know
I got to put money to the side for my
gas and if it's only be 40 bucks I got
to put 80 bucks there were reports of
some stations hiking up their gas prices
gas prices it's nothing new it's been
handled for years back in L.A it was a
Year's way but gas was rationed
get your cash from going to work others
that the pumps say they rather focus on
other things in a ruptured pipeline or
high gas prices it's not that big a deal
for me the most important thing for me
is to have a job if I'm working I'm in
good shape regardless of the tax rates
regardless of inflation
now that emergency declaration made by
the governor and County allowed for
waivers to suspend hours of service
regulations when it came to gas
deliveries reporting live along MLK new
altar Josh pereiro 8 News Now
Governor Lombardo says the state of
emergency will remain in effect until
Emergency Management Partners confirm
Supply is fully returned to normal
residents are also warned to be aware of
price gouging we have the link to report
local price gouging at 8newsnow.com